well I I find this a very emotional
moment but I live the way that the cafe
liturgy Embraces both sadness and hope
so there's a deep sense of sadness
because this is the end of a new year I
think an end of that partnership between
John Paul II and Benedict that lasted
almost 40 years so that is now over but
also this ceremony is marked with such a
Resolute and strong faith in the
promises of Christ that after death we
enter a new phase of our life and
there's a lovely prayer there saying
father show now Benedict the face of
Jesus and that he may be in peace and
that we may be encouraged on our journey
so it's that combination of sadness and
faithful hope
we do of course enter a new era or
perhaps re-enter a familiar era where
there is only one person who has been
named as Pope in the world
how do you think Pope francis's
leadership might change from today
I wouldn't expect to know change frankly
I think Pope Francis has always been
clear in his own mind as what he wants
to achieve he's a very determined
individual as a steel that runs through
the middle of Pope Francis and I think
his relationship with Benedict has been
one of great affection and warmth but
not something that has
changed the way that he has approached
his task as the Supreme pontiff so I
think he will carry on in a determined
way he's already announced a full
program for this coming year and I think
he will miss the presence of Pope
Benedict because he's spoken of him as
an elder brother and and he'll miss his
peripheral presence but I wouldn't
expect change in the way he leads the
church
do you think he will see as a precedent
his predecessor's decision to retire or
or not is that a one-off or is it could
that now become the norm do you think
well I I think we have to understand it
in the changing circumstances of how we
human beings age you know now we can
sustain life even when people are
burdened with quite considerable
incapacities or limitations so I I think
in that sense if a pope got to the point
where he physically or mentally he was
just not right anymore then I would
imagine that there would be a further
retirement to stepping down but I I
think we should remember that Pope
Benedict when he stepped down he was
already 85 and he was aging and he knew
his infirmity so I think he had them
might this might well happen again in
the future but I wouldn't wait for some
announcement from Pope Francis tomorrow
saying I'm off I don't think so he's got
an agenda he wants to continue to follow
it and develop it with great vigor
and finally my impression of today was a
great deal of warmth people have
repeatedly said to me they enjoyed this
occasion more than they felt sadness
yeah how much do you relate to that no I
I think that's true though I must admit
that for me I knew Pope Benedict
recently well and and I do feel a real
sadness and a sense of loss but I think
that warmth also was a reflection of his
personality I think as we look back on
his life the thing that remains with
people was he was a real gentleman you
know he was a gentle man and he had not
just great Insight but great sensitivity
and anybody who met him came away with
that sense of a man who was warm who was
courteous with to whom you could relate
no matter the difficulties that were
being tackled and I think that's what
spread as it were among people today
here we're saying goodbye to somebody
who's just lovely